es un premio que podría hacer que la
moda contaminara menos eso es lo que
esperamos Sí eso es lo que esperamos la
muda sabe que tiene un problema y la
nueva generación es aún más consciente
de ello Es estupendo ver que de todos
modos las restricciones a menudo sirven
para fomentar la creatividad creo que
por desgracia estamos llegando al final
de lo que Este planeta puede soportar y
lo mismo ocurre con nosotros De hecho si
los niños de hoy en día son mejores que
nosotros eso ya es algo bueno de todas
maneras eso es lo que tenemos que
decirnos a nosotros mismos
[Música]
el premio en cuestión lo concede de
Walmart Company una empresa australiana
sin ánimo de lucro creadora de la
etiqueta Walmart que significa que un
producto está compuesto 100% de lana
virgen
tenemos 65.000 agricultores australianos
que quieren promocionar su fibra y dar a
conocer la nuestra y lo hacemos a través
de este premio es uno de los premios más
prestigiosos que existen utilizamos esta
plataforma para crear conciencia de la
fibra para que la gente pueda celebrarla
la primera edición tuvo lugar en 1954
dos jóvenes estilistas ganan el premio
exo q se convierten en estrellas
ifs y Carl lagerfeld 69 años después los
diseñadores de todos los continentes se
apresuran a probar suerte porque para
conseguir una dotación de 200.000
dólares australianos unos 130.000 euros
y un programa de tutoría pero también
por el reto los finalistas han diseñado
colecciones realizadas completamente en
lana de Oveja respetando los requisitos
de un modo de vestir portátil duradero y
no contaminante se lo mostraré
este suéter es de doble faz con
diferentes colores en el reverso
hemos podido desarrollarlo con una
fábrica que conocimos en el premio
Walmart
y estamos encantados con el resultado
puedes ponértelo en verano Y también en
invierno
miembro del Jurado creo que viniendo de
mi lado es siempre es el lado mercantil
de las cosas Te das cuenta de que
quieres encontrar emoción creo que si
pensamos en los diseñadores que hemos
conocido hoy han construido sus negocios
sobre la base de ser más circulares de
usar menos de tener una huella de
carbono más pequeña todos ellos se han
fijado objetivos para un determinado año
para ser ya saben cero residuos netos y
realmente objetivos significativos lo
que fue muy agradable de ver hoy con
este nuevo grupo de diseñadores
nuestra marca está inscrita en lo que
llamamos el sueño americano el yin es
fundamental para el mercado americano al
igual que para Nuestra Empresa como
California es uno de los mayores
productores de tela de Jean nos
preguntamos Por qué no hacer tela de
ginkong lana usted sabe 100% lana
entonces padece De hecho no es una
opción es la última posibilidad no hay
otra opción llegué a Estados Unidos a
filipinas con muy poco dinero cada
centímetro que nosotros gastamos era
para en lo que íbamos a utilizarlo ya
estábamos siendo sostenibles por eso me
resulta tan difícil crear cosas que no
sean más que Caprichos de mi imaginación
mi vida es real y quiero que las cosas
sean reales entonces dentro de Nuestro
objetivo está crear un
para reemplazar la tela de jin Portland
el siguiente reto es reemplazar el cuero
por lana eso es lo novedoso y las
restricciones inspiran la creatividad
es lo que Carlos siempre ha dicho y es
lo que yo siempre he pensado eso ayuda
la sostenibilidad es una característica
que mucha gente de la moda valora mucho
realmente se ha convertido en una
obligación cuando trabajas en una
industria que es extremadamente
contaminante tenemos que tomar las
decisiones correctas aunque se tomen más
tarde de lo debido es absolutamente
necesario que lo hagamos el premio Carl
lagerfeld a la innovación ha sido
conseguido a la diseñadora danesa
amalijo hof creo que esta chaqueta
combina muy bien El Fuerte ADN de la
marca pero también los nuevos los
desarrollos que hemos hecho con la lana
porque ya saben realmente tenemos este
marco la técnica que deja ver el revés
de la lana creo que es una pieza Que
invita al diálogo a preguntarse cómo
está hecha Cómo se comportan los
distintos materiales a no ocultar nada a
que el proceso sea transparente y
también en esta pieza se puede ver cómo
está ella
el gran premio por su parte fue para el
diseñador nigeriano de YouTube Thompson
el concepto de mi colección se basa en
la corriente de pensamiento descolonizar
el diseño revelar y romper con las ideas
falsas que tenemos del diseño africano
es mucho más de lo que se puede pensar
hay una historia una historia de
minimalismo la moda africana es a la vez
muy compleja y vulnerable estoy muy
orgulloso de ser reconocido por el
trabajo que hago qué va a hacer con este
premio voy a invertirlo en mi empresa y
voy a lanzarlo estoy como Guau
Este es un homenaje a África África
hemos visto que en varios premios los
diseñadores africanos están destacándose
Y creo que es muy importante no solo
apoyar sino también tener algo nuevo en
el mercado de la moda los diseñadores
africanos están emergiendo porque
ofrecen una visión diferente
tienen una hermosa herencia y una
calidad artesanal que es muy agradable
de ver en las redes de la moda
el tema del premio wilmark de este año
era el diálogo una celebración del tipo
de intercambios que hacen que la moda
sostenible sea también cada vez más una
moda deseable